ein 10 mal 20 meter großer fernseher
hinter deinem 70 millionen quadratmeter
großen pool diese 50 euro ich weiß nicht
wie ich dieses video hier am besten an
moderieren soll
aber wir reagieren heute gemeinsam auf 1
250 millionen dollar haus in den bergen
von los angeles
also nochmal wocheneinkauf ja also das
ist die adresse in elf als designer von
euch besichtigen will wundert euch bitte
nicht dass hier gerade kein richtiger
ton vom video ist sondern um eine
hintergrundmusik weil das video hat
keinen ton danke dass ihr noch mal 250
millionen dollar hin schreibt damit man
sich auch noch ärmer fühlt also das
video hat keinen ton sondern nur so eine
komische werbemusik im hintergrund
deswegen hört ihr hier meine mutter hier
steigt eine frau ist in einem helikopter
der wahrscheinlich auch noch im preis
mit drin ist aus ihm und sie schaut sich
um und da unten steht ein bugatti
nicht mal den könnte ich mir leisten das
ist das haus von oben ms sieht auf jeden
fall jetzt muss ich ganz ehrlich gesagt
zu geben nicht nach einem 250 millionen
dollar teuren haus aus sss sieht es
sieht da steht dann auch ein ferrari
ja jetzt doch ein bisschen teurer aus
also hier vorne ist eine eigene einfahrt
hier vorne stehen die karren ich glaube
dass wir vorne auch porsche lag ein
porsche waren mein gott das gab das habe
ich das
das ist ja größer als das größte
schwimmbad in dem ich je war
irgendwie will ich das video weiter
anschauen aber irgendwie auch nicht weil
wir dann noch beschissener geht in
meinem leben aber gut wir schauen mal
weiter
wir sehen auf jeden fall dass das ganze
hier über mehrere etagen auch ist was
auch sonst bei 250 millionen euro das
hier ist das ganze anwesen
wir sehen hier die ganzen karren hier
ist der helikopter hier sind irgendwie
es ist auch alles irgendwie begrünt mit
rasen der perfekt ist das ist ein pagani
weiß nicht genau das ist ein modell ist
ich glaube ich glaube das ist ein pagani
huayra dc oder irgendwie so heiser der
hier hoch fährt aber ich weiß auch nicht
ganz genau
sofern ich das jetzt richtig erkennen
könnte die karte nur zur info kostet so
um die drei millionen euro die ganzen
karree das ist auf jeden fall die garage
die auch irgendwie vielleicht anteil
davon ist also die man mit kauft
entstehen oldtimer drin den kannst du
doch nicht mal rausfahren da muss noch
die anderen teile erst mal alle um
parken hier stehen und vor allem hier
dann auch noch das sieht aus wie bei
sontheimer verkaufs unternehmen also ich
habe keine ahnung was hier auch gerade
wieder abgeht hier sind bowlingkugeln du
hast eine eigene bowlingbahn
wir wollten letztes bowlen gehen und ich
habe kein geld dabei dass ich konnte
nicht bei einem normalen boardinghouse
in köln wollen gehen wir fordern ist
irgendwie samt schild zimmer das er
nicht nur eine bowlingbahn sondern
mehrere tatsächlich hier sind motoren
ausgestellt und hier ist ein eigenes
dein eigenes dein eigenes kino hier mit
die vollelektronische und dann
hochfahren falls man mal seine 70.000
freunde einladen will für ein kinoabend
also das ist ja echt mega entspannt
haben das ganze kino ist elektrisch also
man kann da alles umfang um die vier
plätze sind 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 und das x 5
also 40 plätze
hey
so viele freunde habe ich nicht mal das
hier ist eine eigene süßigkeiten wand
wurde die irgendwie sachen abfüllen
kannst hier sind waren geraten kicker da
war eine tischtennisplatte und ein
billardtisch
ich weiß nicht was das hier gerade ist
aber das ist ja alles noch das gleiche
stockwerk das irritiert mich so ein
bisschen da wo die karten sind das ist
hier war scheint also wird aber
zusammenzufassen wahrscheinlich ist das
so der play
ich würde sagen zimmer aber sind mehrere
zimmer von der die play etage guckt mal
er hat sogar fünf verschiedene fernseher
programme die was auch immer da das ist
irgendwie sondern tresor wo er dann
wahrscheinlich noch sein ganzes gold und
die ganzen diamanten hinter hat bzw
ich weiß gar nicht ob das haus überhaupt
verkauft wurde oder ob es immer noch zum
verkaufsmanager dass videos von vor drei
jahren also vermutlich wird eingekauft
haben aber das ist ja unfassbar krass
allein diese kamera schaut ihr euch mal
an die ist ja denn diese lockert 23
meter lang
das ist der blick über los angeles den
sieht man hier mit der sonne natürlich
lasse was kannst du nur in los angeles
bauen mit dem wetter dann rund um die
jahreszeit was ich bin so ich kann ich
kann nicht nach reden was ich wollen
sagen wollte war auf jeden fall dass du
so was natürlich nur in los angeles so
richtig bauen kannst oder in dubai oder
keine ahnung wo es an orten wo es
wirklich fast nie regnet
weil es halt hier der fall ist dass sie
sehr sehr sehr sehr viel auch mit indoor
outdoor living in der ordnung space
gearbeitet haben was ist denn das jetzt
hier eigentlich das sind so gummibärchen
irgendwas rumkriegen aber okay das ist
auf jeden fall die küche die sieht
tatsächlich aus wie einfach eine sehr
sehr sehr sehr luxuriöse küche also bei
250 millionen hätte ich mir ein bisschen
mehr da das noch eine küche
und immer halt diese hervor scheinende
blick über komplett los angeles
ich würde es nehmen ich sah das dann in
raten monatlich 30 euro und dann wäre
ich fertig 250 millionen durch 30 euro
ich war fertig in 8,3 millionen monaten
also im jahren in 700.000 jahren
abbezahlt habe jetzt mal real talk ich
will das jetzt wirklich gerade mal
ausrechnen dass den kopf 250 millionen
us-dollar sagen wir mal man zahlt
monatlich wirklich 2000 euro was eine
menge ist dann müsste 125000 monate und
das in jahren sind 10.000 jahre
noch eine allerletzte rechnungen sagen
wir mal ich lebe noch 60 jahre das heißt
wir rechnen 250 millionen us dollar
durch 60 jahre das heißt ich müsste pro
jahr 4,16 millionen euro zahlen das
heißt monatlich 350.000 euro
damit ich das ding abbezahlt habe wenn
ich tot bin
ja wir schon weiter habe das hier ist
das arbeitszimmer von der person
hier werden noch mal die karten gezeigt
hier bentley rolls royce und dann
bugatti veyron brown hat dann eben hier
vorne ein eigenes gym ist ja logisch
also klar dass auch noch ein gym mit
drin ist eine schöne frau zeigen wieder
läuft das jetzt wieder in der outdoor
living wollte ich also hab ich ja gerade
schon gesagt hat ist hat für ein riesen
podlas eigene kleine teile die deinen
pool an pissen sogar ich komme wirklich
nicht auf dieses haus klar meine lieben
freunde hier oben auch immer noch so der
helikopter der da so ein bisschen ein
händler hervor stelle manchem vorne
warnten dass das ist jetzt nicht wahr
das ist das ist dass es
fernseher
ein 10 mal 20 meter großer fernseher
hinter deinem 70 millionen quadratmeter
großen pool diese 50 euro
das kann doch nicht wahr sein erfährt
dann sonst fernseher hinter deinem pool
hoch wenn du mal keinen bock mehr auf
die kommt das an
das ist ein eigener raum nur für den
fernseher ich möchte schaut euch das an
freunde das kann doch nicht wahr sein
hier unten ist die komplette garage in
dieser play ruhm wahrscheinlich hier
oben ist alles so private mäßig das kann
das ist doch ist doch nicht von dieser
welt ich frage mich wirklich was die uns
noch zeigen wollen weil auch jetzt würde
ich schon sagen das ist das krasseste
aus das ich je gesehen habe also ich
meine ich selbst könnte da nicht
einziehen bei mir das viel zu offen wäre
und ich viel zu viel angst davor hatte
dass irgendwelche leute mehr was klauen
wollen oder da einbrechen aber
wahrscheinlich haben sie auch noch eine
alarmanlage für 70 millionen euro
eingebaut auf jeden fall geht es nun
allerdings noch mal in den raum ist das
glaube ich oder ein massageraum hier
hängt auch so kunst von wegen voll krass
fiel ein renten und dehnen und so weiter
und so fort ist ein eigener friseursalon
last butler man man hat einen ein butler
das ist der eingangsbereich hier ist
auch dass man mal im hier ist noch mal
ein anderes zimmer da hier ist jetzt
auch noch so ein zimmer dann dass das
ist dass das ist keine ahnung was das
ist aber bestimmt auch voll teuer das
ist dann jetzt und golfplatz natürlich
klar man hat man dann auch noch eine
katze golf spielen wie man schon sieht
eine mega trifft er wohl ja hat er nicht
hier ist auch noch ein zimmer ich kann
mir das nicht mehr anschauen
es geht noch einer
das kann ich jetzt auch noch zu gemüte
führen so ist der ausblick auf jeden
fall das ist ja wahnsinn wenn ich hier
raus schau ist wie ich nach außen
asiatinnen gerade am zimmer dahinter hat
ist das schlafzimmer mich hier sind wir
dann die da draußen mit dem blick das
ist das andere schlafzimmer das ist das
dritte schlafzimmer im haus tatsächlich
dazu eigenen kamins auch wahnsinn dann
weiter geht's mit einer vergoldeten
hermès kettensäge die natürlich
selbstverständlich auf den küchentresen
romantisch für circa 70 leute das ist
ein innenhof ist wirklich wahnsinnig
jetzt noch eine time lab wurde
helikopter dann sogar beleuchtet ist mit
denen wahrscheinlich versilberten
scheinwerfern hier das ist dann ganz bei
nacht wahnsinn hammer ich kann nicht
mehr
wenn ihr euch das haus kaufen wollt hier
findet ihr einen instagram schreibt mir
gerne nach richtig vermittelt euch dann
und das geld was im iran gibt dass ich
da noch definitiv weitergehen man die
person
andersherum ich das heute wieder soll es
auch beenden meine lieben freunde das
geht zwar noch eine halbe minute aber
ich kann mir das wirklich schon wer also
redet man fragt sich bei sowas halt
wirklich einfach immer was habe ich
falsch gemacht im leben weil die würden
das haus nicht bauen wenn sie nicht
denken würden hey das wird sich
irgendjemand mal kaufen ja aber gut
meine lieben freunde das video wird an
der stelle jetzt aber wie gerade bereit
schon gesagt auch beenden wenn es euch
gefallen hat das gerne einen daumen hoch
unter dem video he da schreibt ihr gerne
unten in die kommentare auf was ich als
nächstes reagieren soll vielleicht gibt
ja noch andere häuser die noch teurer
sind als eine viertel milliarden us
dollar eine million abonnenten einen
kanal jetzt auch keinerlei crew seit
wenn ich dann mal einklicken auf die
glocke bekommt ihr die benachrichtigung
wenn ich neue hochladen und jetzt kommt
das auto
[Musik]